Ladies and gentlemen,
we are live,
live on the podcast with the voice.
Michael Chavela,
a meeting of the minds,
ladies and gentlemen,
to mixed martial arts soon as if you
will,
together on a podcast sponsored by the
way,
by the flashlight,
as always.
Now they have a new avatar version.
Now it's not really avatar.
They can't say Avatar,
but you know what?
You're fucking blue vagina.
These are like that.
But in Tokyo they could tenders over
there.
They're huge sellers,
a don quixote stores,
which for us mixed martial arts fans
don't.
God is also the major sponsor of sin.
Goku really?
So they've got no,
it's a store where you can buy
everything from fashion to food to
fucking sick like this.
And they sell these things called Tinga
at similar to this,
but a bit smaller because the Japanese
have really small cocks.
Sorry,
it's all about Japanese fans,
but you do.
And yet the guys buy these things,
tenders and they rip the leaves off.
Fuck him.
And well,
uh,
this is,
this is the only sponsor I have for the
show.
Well,
I've,
I've Kinda a couple other ones.
But,
you know,
in the MP three versions,
but this,
um,
this company was sponsored by a guy
whose wife was pregnant and uh,
his,
he couldn't fuck her obviously,
so he invented something to funk,
came up with something to fuck and now
he's rich.
I mean it's like his own personal.
Like they,
they,
they came up with all these patents for
what makes it feel the most like a
pussy.
It's really fantastic shit.
Like if you're feeling really fucking
stick your cock in there.
No,
I didn't.
I wouldn't do that to you promise me the
one that fucking show longer.
You have not done that.
I would not do that to you.
I would only give you a clean one.
Oh,
you spit into fingertip.
Woo.
I feel dirty.
Am.
Yeah.
It's pretty,
pretty cool.
Well,
you know what I liked the most about it
though,
that there's been a bunch of controversy
about it.
I think may have people called me.
Dude when he was doing.
He just got this.
I just got this last week.
May Have touched on.
I might have given them one.
I'll give you one if you want.
I got some extra.
That's right.
I got my girlfriend here once she got on
the road,
then I know what you're saying is
everything many times rather than
blindly times on the road.
Cantaloupes in the microwave.
I only discovered like 12 months ago
that the Japanese toilets all have a
shoot water into your ass.
Right?
So Ivan,
what my ass in Japan for the last 10
months because it shoots water in your
house and cleans your house yet.
But that's really the way to do it.
So I had to go and uh,
warms a seat.
Warmers.
The seat tilts from side to side.
But if you shift back a little bit more,
it goes from your so shoots onto your
bolts.
So the Japanese tourists can fumble your
balls,
you're lonely nights on the road and
fondled and get the moisturizer.
So that's what you do from the bull
senseless men on the road.
So I prepare for fight commentary.
How do you prepare?
Do you prepare it to like sit down with
a,
you know,
almost everything there is to know about
all these guys that are fighting.
I mean,
you're,
the one thing that I appreciate about
you is just like me,
like if you weren't doing this,
you'd still be watching it just as much
still,
man.
Lucky.
I'm a fan.
You know,
he's over here tonight,
so we're going to watch strikeforce.
We're buddies.
We met in Edmonton and we hung out in
Australia and now he's at my house and
we're going to watch the fight tonight.
Yeah.
I can't.
The man I just don't feel a lot to do
before I commentate is.
I'd just like to listen to music,
man,
a monopod,
listen to music.
I don't talk very much.
Like,
um,
last last year we draft a dynamite which
from the hotel to go to St Dahmer in
Tokyo.
It's like a 50 minute drive and in the
cab was like me and Irene and one of
your producers and I said to both of
them get you to talk to each other
because I'm put these headphones on and
just,
I don't talk to anyone who's fired up
on.
Yeah,
just like to be in a good state of mind
when you get a good state of mind.
I dude,
I play some cheesy us songs like,
seriously,
if you sold the 10 songs I play before I
go on in is cheesy.
I was like,
what do you do?
Not Get everything from the theme from
Joe Esposito theme from karate kid you
the best around,
right?
You know that one said like the theme
from fucking grace,
like songs from the musical greats.
Really?
Yeah.
We achieved too excited for real.
I like the hand Jive,
the grease handjobs song.
Really do that hinge a baby that wasn't
right.
I'm like,
cool.
I'm actually going there and come and
take you on and dream.
I'm like hand jive.
That would drive me crazy.
Oh Man.
One man's poison.
Yeah.
I fucking love it.
That's it.
I just,
you know,
I'll make sure I'm well prepared.
I do in my research and all that sort of
shit.
But I know most of the guys anyway.
I like some bad music.
What do you like?
I like some country music.
That's terrible.
You really could have been a cowboy.
Like that song.
I liked some.
I liked some dumb toby keith style
country music.
I like good country music too.
I liked like Hank Williams Jr.
I like that matt hughes song.
Country boy kenscI viola.
I fucking love that song.
That's a goddaMn man.
But now everyone is too gangsta.
Aaron is tHe end of the dialogue shit.
Some guys don't to see him.
I'm out fucking mama.
Papa.
Kathy's motherfuckers gangSter in rmb to
you sing.
You're a singer for living.
You know what would have happened to me
if I told my dad when I was six years
old,
daddy I want to be a singer.
He would have fuCking get out on the
street.
Well they don't like to think of
themselves as Being the,
that's a feminine thing.
So they overcompensate.
I sing for a fucKing.
He's not singing right?
Wrapping sort of wrapping.
It's just fast talking to shit.
This is shit talk like I hate everybody
or a rhythm to it.
So it is kind of like musical,
but yeah.
But I like old r and b,
like I loVe marvin gaye.
Like that motherfucker just had a voice
man.
But I don't like the new stuff because I
don't believe them.
That's what I'm saying.
Like r kelly,
I love art because it's funny man,
because it's so ridiculous.
You got unlucky urinating on my
motherfucking.
He's saying that.
I mean these things is like a ghetto
conversation and he just puts it to the
song.
I could appreciate that.
But you know,
every second word is an ad.
It's like a bad word,
a taboo word.
Like nigga,
you know,
we don't have that in Australia.
JusT quality one that there's many black
people in Australia,
but every sixth word doesn't even exist.
We wouldn't really know.
So it's like americans calling someone
an abo,
aba,
aboriginal aboriginal ebo.
It doesn't exist over here.
When you call someone,
hey,
you fucking abok.
And they'll go,
okay,
what?
I'll call a black guy in american abok.
He goes,
that nigger is going to kill me.
But if you call an aborigine and abbo
it's the same thing as call them and
they'll pull picture on you and set you
on fire.
But just a short version of aborigine.
Yeah,
you got to turn that shit off,
son.
Dismiss alarm.
I don't know why it sounded like five in
the afternoon.
Time to get your balls fall by the
toilet.
You got that shit a clock.
You sick.
Fuck,
you're right.
It's,
it's,
it's an abbreviation.
It's like if you're jewish and I say
you're a jew,
doesn't matter if that original ebo
yeah,
italian.
I tie once I submit.
It's truly an ozzy.
Yeah.
What's wrong with that hyping called
apo.
I made a statement once saying the japs
have created some insane shit and this
guy goes,
do you know how racist that is?
He just said that.
I'm like,
whAt we're talking about nsx is we're
talking about engineering,
like japanese racecar engineering,
like they've invented some incredible
shit.
Their cars are so reliable and so I
said,
the japs have invented some incredible
shit.
This guy's like,
do you know racist?
That is like,
I had this argument last year with
someone because I called someone a jack
back home and it's lucky.
It's luck.
The world war two alliance thing that
it's racist to call jack and I've got to
get past that silicon around japanese
people for years and I'm sure have
called them jepthah to the fights and I
don't mind.
and in my mates like,
dude,
it's so fucking racist and it's wrong.
You can't cite japa baba.
so I went to Japan and I ask my
producer.
I said,
dude,
if I call you a jap,
are you offended?
You guys know it's short for japanese.
We've got no offense.
You don't fucking start thinking pill
harbor and you know,
we use the bombs on hiroshima and people
thought the nips was far too offensive.
JuSt that's how the japanese say,
Japan,
they don't say Japan,
they say Nepal and some people are
retarded.
It's a strange thing where people don't
want to step on people's toes over
nonsense like an abbreviation of a name
is bad,
but hands is the only thing that's bad
intent.
It's all in.
How do you feel like you need to say
these jobs are fucking bad ass and make
some cool shit?
Or do you take these japs,
these little tiny cock yellow
motherfuckers coming over here to fuck
all the white women and take all the
land and you can start getting angry?
Well then jabs is a bad thing,
but that's the intent behind it.
That's bad to breathe the fucking nation
man nation.
so people are always looking for a
reason to be pissed off.
People are so pissed off just about life
itself,
about traffic and bullshit and bills and
the constant midnight.
Everybody has a fuckIng opinion this
day,
man.
Why can some people just shut up?
Let the fucking.
What qualifies you to have a fucking
opinion that I should pay attention for?
Are you sitting behind your website
fucking getting paid to put your opinion
on it?
No.
Well even the ones who are.
There's a lot of websites out there that
are.
There's a lot of bloggers,
in my opinion,
that aren't.
Aren't nearly as good as some of the
commentary guys who post on like mixed
martial arts.com.
There's some fucking intelligent guys
that I've been reading their posts for
years and if there.
I know that if there's a post about
anything like serious,
well this guy,
if he posts soMething about it,
this is going to be an interesting
opinion.
I want to read this,
but how many writers can you say that
about?
I'm a writer.
I think there's more talented People on
forums.
The other thing we him a might rod is is
they are blinded to anything outside of
the ufc and I love the ufc because I'm a
fucking huge josh grosses.
Josh crushed pretty old brush.
One of the rare ones.
There's a few that aren't,
but a lot of them are blind to that.
He's not ufc.
They might be scared,
might be scared.
It's going to be yanKed their
credentials from.
From,
from dana.
Dana,
dana.
I know it's creepy,
but a lot of them don't even know
anything about marsh lots,
bro.
You could not sit down and have a
conversation really about martial arts
with them.
It's,
you know,
and dana is so competitive that he does
have this environment where he feels
like they should pay attention to the
ufc first and then if they don't,
he's not very happy with that.
You'll see is the,
it's the promotion.
It is the one you go to a plantation,
that attitude in the pushing it like
that as the reason why this fucking
sports gigantic.
The reason why it's going Australia,
he's not lazy.
He's,
he's taken on all fronts,
you know,
so it's,
it's tough for journalists,
you know,
in the,
in that sense,
you know,
but theRe are soMe fucking talented guys
out there,
you know,
like josh gross is a talented
journalist,
you know,
and he's,
he's honest aBout shed.
He's sometimes he's a little hyper
critical,
but sometimes guys get like critical
about dudes abilities and characters and
they try to say something bitchy because
if someone puts in a bad performance
they'll just,
they feel like,
you know,
it's their job to be critical and to be
shitty,
bitter,
bitter to fucking wrote about.
I did the keY perfect prison.
Perfect of.
But what do you say about like a cro cop
in amir fight when cro cop in me or
fight man,
there's not a lot of positive things to
say.
The positive thing to say is the end of
the fight.
Of course frank mir landed a perfect
knee and put krakow away and then
finished them,
you know,
jumped all over him.
So that's a good thing to say.
But for everything up before that,
what cota writer say,
you know,
so they just start going off about,
the just the worst possible shit that
they could think of.
You know,
what's wrong with frank mir and how,
you know,
he's got this attitude and cro cop
should hang it up and they'll just write
the most bitter fucked up shit.
You know,
I think that the human drama is far more
compelling.
The real drama of that fight,
you know?
So that was a strange fight,
man that fought the liked each other or
something came out and he said,
even if I lose,
I'm not going to get cut from you have
say.
So.
When I read that,
I'm like,
I don't want to fucking saY this.
Fully.
Say that.
He came out and said one of the websites
like medical essays.
Even if I lose,
I can't get cut.
well,
if that's the case,
I don't want to fucking watch that
fight,
man.
Because already I know that.
I'm not sure if you've that give you a
head.
I'm not sure if he really said that.
I these words maybe misconstrued very
could be taken out of context.
If you lose this fight,
do you think you'll be kicked out of the
ufc?
I hope not.
Marco says he won't be kicked out of the
ufc if he loses his fight.
Journalism sometimes is that bad?
So misconstrued saved exactly what I
supposedly said and I was like,
I didn't say it like that.
You know,
you're missing.
That has been the big difference,
bro.
Between commentatIng outside of America
and then recently coming onto the
american scene.
It's like you could people that sit
there and watch the broadcast and
analyze every fucking word and pause and
breath you take and then dissect that
down to the line.
It's bad and it's negative,
but I also think it's good for me
personally.
It's good.
I've,
I've learned a lot from shitty people
online saying shitty things because you
know,
worst case scenario,
what can they attack you on?
Is there any validity in this total
piece of shit was saying terrible things
about you,
but do they have a point and if they do
have a point then you can like snatch
victory from the older negative bullshit
by using and improving it and why if you
use a positively it x is a watch dog for
your own abilities and your appearances
on her toe to total console.
I get personal freedom out of like
reading the shittiest,
nastiest things that like I know just
some desperate angry fuck has and
turning it into a positive thing for me.
Like I have this little game that I
played with because it's very dIfficult
to do.
I want to do like solen bob and on the
fuck is that when you read,
when you reached out to get mad?
I used to it man.
You know,
it's like as I.
I tend not to read a lot of it because
it's was like,
what am I going to do?
Sit there and read it and go,
wow,
I'm so super and fantastic because
people are giving me these compliments
and then you read people a little bag.
Your wHy.
It's good to know that people are
enjoying what you do need to know and to
connect with them and I saw you did that
recently on the underground.
You made my first time on the.
On the ground.
Yeah,
there's plenty of cool people in there
and I post on there all the time.
There's plenty of cool people there.
There's going to be douche bags no
matter what.
When you have anonymous scream names and
people can say anything they want,
whenever you have that situation is
going to be sure dog,
which has got some great posts,
but also some really fucking ridiculous
boo fuck is on there as well and so many
profiles that I know in so many media
guys,
just one post on sites like that anymore
because of the reason that people just
attack and attack like fucking puranas
man.
This a lot of hateful fucks out there
and I'm hateful for it's,
but it's a fascinating thing man,
because we're finally getting to see
that.
Like everyone gets to see that noW.
It used to be,
you never got to see that.
If you were a star,
you know,
stars.
I think just 20 years ago we're were
much more likely to be believing their
own bullshit.
yeah.
Back then they never saw shit and if it
gotten a magazine they approved it.
You know,
if I got a newspaper,
it had to be like big news,
like roman polanski type news to make it
in the newspaper.
But now man,
they're all up in your shit everyday
man.
Everything is just taken apart and
dissect that.
Twitter,
I'm going to use the twitter with
twitter is not being in Australia,
dude to people in Australia who know
about twitter?
No one twin is.
Everyone's on fucking facebook.
Oh,
nolan tweeters in Australia.
Some people are still stuck on my space.
Both twitter and facebook on mine are
connected.
So if I said something on twitter,
it goes to facebook.
It says it there too.
So you lost soda,
nightmare technology.
Your house is like fucking nasser in
here,
man.
Shit.
I'm a technology junkie.
Food.
Unbelievable.
Fascinated by what's going on with
technology.
Seriously.
Leave any higher up on a fucking
mountain over.
They.
When I was living in Colorado,
this bleed drying up here,
man.
this ain't shit.
This is civilization.
Compared to where I was living.
I was living.
I was living eight miles down a dirt
road on the top of a mountain in
boulder.
Fuck man.
That's why I like to live.
I like to live up and above so that when
like waves of water or waves,
retards,
neither waves of water,
a range of retards.
You see him coming up the hill.
I just don't.
I just like being away.
I think I'm very sensitive to people's
energy and people's thoughts and their
lives and their bullshit.
So I like to be as when I sleep and when
I'm at home and when I'm writing,
when I'm by myself,
I like to be as far away from people as
possible.
I like,
man,
it's cool because all the houses here at
different than all of the same.
Now the guided communities I've seen
here in the states,
because we don't have gated communities
in all the houses,
look the same though,
and up here they're all different and on
the guard gate is to.
God haS this to god's name.
Ralph once I'm judy,
I read the andreessen,
there's three of them,
two of them,
and I'm man.
Maybe it's a conspiracy rule,
man in the world,
like those coca cola inventors that they
had to be at least 50 feet apart from
each other at all times.
You know?
It's like he never see to relevant what
is in the sacred cola.
Inventors had to be 50 feet apart from
each other.
never hear that.
Urban legend is a kid.
No.
Let the inventors of coca cola or the is
of kfc,
Kentucky fried chicken with the secret
recipe that I carry around on them all
the time.
Must at least be fIfty feet apart of one
of them dies.
The other ones,
one of them dies from the other one
survives.
Wow.
Could you imagine if a recipe was that
valuable?
The kfc secret spice.
Nothing will fuck up your appetite like
watching.
One of those pita videos I love fucking
children's urban legends.
Mandarin at scHool told you about about
being a black belt.
When the kid sits me in grade five,
we'll talking about martial arts and
he's like,
you can't be any more than it third dan
black belt in Australia,
or you've got to get out of the country
because you're then lethal weapon and
have a license to kill.
I believed that for years,
man,
that I would probably believe it too.
Wow.
You just can't get to deadly.
I guess.
Speaking about urban legends,
do you get the same ones that we do
here?
Did you guys get the richard gere jubal
room?
Oh,
in the ass?
Yes.
I didn't get that man because We didn't
know what tables work because we call
them a finger is what we call a Guinea
pig and we have Guinea pigs.
Guinea pigs are much bigger though.
What's a job?
It's almost like.
Yeah,
it's like a mouse.
No,
people genuinely
stick up there.
If you look,
if you've thought of it,
someone's put it up their ass.
That's a fact,
and I knew about this.
I didn't want to know about this,
but I knew about my buddy steve graham,
who is a friend of mine from back when I
was like 15 years old and still still
good friends.
He's a doctor and he did his residency
in miami and he said he got to see
everything.
Tell me about gunshot wounds and
everyday they'd be pulling some new
thing out.
A dude's assets.
Becky melbourne,
a doctor friend of mine,
great doctor to go to dinner with
[inaudible] you'll tell you are stories
for hours.
He pulled a working dildo.
The dIldo was too long in a guy's colon.
It was large.
It went so fucking cry and he had some
milk out of the guy's fucking colon and
shoot it out of his ass and the deal
that was still on some other guy in
there and had a fucking brim,
a fish up his ass.
Fuck breeam.
Appease off.
The thing that shocked my friend the
most was glass and he said a lot of
glass up there ass those bottles and
jars and jars break and.
Oh no.
The freakiest one member dr told me was
it wasn't about us,
was two gay guys that came to see him.
The one gay guy came to see him and he
had problem with his cock is cockatiel
this passing shit coming out of it.
So dr.
Nix had a look at.
He's cocky now.
He's gone.
I just don't know what I'm seeing here
too.
It's like,
what have,
what have you been doing?
What would the reason for this be?
So the gay guy proceeded to tell him he
thought,
well,
this might be the reason what him and
his gay lover with doing that we're
getting thin pieces of pipe thin pieces
of piping like this theater,
long pipes.
He would sTick it into his urethra and
then connect the other end who is gay
lovers,
urethra and then they would piss piece
between the rocks.
So he was pissing into his level,
his cock and his love of pc back into
his car and he's gone into the doctor
saying my cox passover at why?
I thought the mix.
Like why the fuck do you thInk you were
sharing your run with another human
being?
With a metal through your deck,
it's rally the metal rod through the
dick that fucked them up more than the
path back and forth.
Pisses basically sterile.
Oh,
and what was the other.
the other sport he told me and that this
fat chick that came in one day like mega
fat,
like you know what's eating gilbert
grape?
That fucking big fat.
Five hundred pounds.
What do you guys use?
Kilos.
Kyla.
So she'd be like 180 kilos bono side.
Five hundred pounds.
Sounds better though.
That's like yuck.
As unit size.
Cool kilos are just too big and you
listen to this fucking gargantuan
behemoth comes in and she came in and
she'd stuck a tampon to fire up her
pussy.
She asked doctor need to get it out.
So we had to give up the pliers,
the tongues and go into the skills
fucking kevin,
right as she got through all the
fentanyl thighs and pull out a tampon.
She came back the next month with the
same problem and she was coming back for
four months in a row with the same
problem.
Sticking your tampon to far per month to
be able to pull it out.
So eventually dr nick realize that when
he was,
because he'd never looked her in the
face because you're not really pulling
shit out of her tampon this time he,
he had,
he had an inkling just like his stick
and tongues up her pussy.
And because this is a fucking animal,
fucking beached whale,
no one's ever going to touch her vet
includes probably never been touched.
And so that felt good to her.
So for her,
he's going inside.
She was like,
oh,
like that.
Oh my gosh,
here realizes,
realizes she's not coming campano up her
pussy so that he'll go get them.
So he would go fishing there and get the
tampons.
For a girl like that,
that shouldn't be a place where you go
guys are just finger you.
I'm all for that.
You know,
when I talk about being for
prostitution,
um,
I'm all for um,
for dudes doing it too.
I'm for jude's eaton girls put susan
finger and I'm sure it gets me that bro.
I never understood what the big deal is
about getting a hand job.
you know,
you get on with it though.
It's way more of a big deal for girl.
What I'm saying for girls is that would
be a sweet spot for them,
like a store where they could see your
fingers and our hands can go through and
just saying that you don't have to go
out with some dude just because you need
sex.
You can just fucking,
you know,
you'd Be all right.
We can get it when you really want to
get Into a relationship behind
sterilized hand,
a little bit of touro stimulation.
During your lunch break,
10 minutes.
Listerine kills all the germs.
Every time you get back to a high
powered afternoon in the office,
I mean,
come on,
look that guy eat your box and just
fingeR back.
You'll feel so much better.
So we doing.
He retires from u of c commentary.
No,
the world's first chain of self
fingering seller.
We need more progress in this world
Before the world.
Ready to accept my idea sir.
True finger banging stations.
The hole in the wall with god's
goodness.
Go stick their junk in a fucking glory
hole and get tossed off by some chick on
the other side of the whole.
Yeah.
What I suggested was frustration.
It would be like a,
uh,
like one of those thIngs where you do
confession.
One of those,
those,
uh,
the professional,
is that what it's called?
And he's like going inside the
professionalized.
They kneel on a pew.
Okay.
So you're in this little phone book
type,
phone booth type situation and you have
a Monitor in front of you.
You can watch some porn and she just
sticks her hand through a hole in the
wall.
Even better,
you can able to watch the monitor of the
girl on the other side checkinG you off.
Yeah.
But what if she's gross?
Like,
you shouldn't even have to be good
looking.
This one,
it's true.
I'Ll just do,
is just be good at and dudes off away.
You don't have to see her franchise
coming.
The house of handoffs handjobs and don't
even get to see what's happening below
your waist.
He's a trained professional to 10
minutes here,
right?
The tension's gone.
The stress has gone.
And you just ready for free for the day.
We can't handle that shit here in
America.
And we're a bunch of pussies.
Yeah,
we don't.
We don't want it.
We want.
We want people to be repressed.
We want people to just be nonsexual.
And we want people to be a slave to
whatever relationship they're in to
americans have super paranoid,
man.
If I was living here and watching your
news every night,
I would fucking be so look out my window
in the United States of America.
You are right now in the balls of the
dick.
That's fucking the world.
All right.
This is a crazy ass place to live.
It is fucked,
man.
It's fucked.
Paranoid people hear stuff far too much.
It's crazy,
man.
You ever watch us?
Do you watch fox news?
This is the worst.
Rupert murdoch.
I watch fox news.
just go,
what the fuck are you talking?
There's too much.
Everyone is.
I mean it's.
And you know,
it's a self fulfilling prophecy to like
they,
they literally manifest their own war
against the liberals.
And d was on fox news.
It was that whole thing about when bush
was voted in for the first time and fox
news did something about the voting
polls.
You know when bush big gore and goal was
actually the guy that won,
wanted the brush,
got ian and fox news had something to do
with the way that they told voters that
push it already won,
but some votes somewhere hadn't been
done or works here in America,
but nobody knows how it works.
Write something aBout It,
man.
Type 30 credits something about do you
want to be spokes?
You know what I love?
I love when one,
when politicians get busted for
something sexual,
anything deviant,
anything.
Sexual fox always makes them a democrat.
It's a long running joke.
It's a long running job,
but if there's some guy he gets caught,
you know,
fucking his babysitter or something like
that to bam di di repo,
Vermont,
you know it's,
oh,
they always.
Even if the guy's a republican,
he always write them down as a democrat
politician that the sexual stuff you get
caught for should just be the most
dirtiest fucking disgusting deprived
shit ever.
You're going to go down as a politician,
go down fucking inflames,
man.
Some deprIve ship.
do you remember that?
Dc man?
Um,
do you know that story?
There's a dc madam who was running some
chain in Washington dc and uh,
she had all these high powered senators
and congressmen,
all these people on her,
on her,
on her list of,
you know,
john's and she was going to release it
and there was some fucking crazy
attention.
She gave him,
you know,
press conferences and the whole deal.
And then she committed suicide.
Just conveniently committed suicide,
committed suicide.
No one said a fucking day.
No one said a thing.
No one was like,
wait a minute,
hold on,
wait a minute.
You're telling me that this woman right
now getting more attention than ever
possibly set to make a million dollars.
She's deciding to hang herself.
Really?
Because I could just pinch your legacy.
I don't know.
Every politician that booklet,
40 of them just caught slipping her at
google.
WhaT?
What they did to her or what?
Which he supposedly did.
Definitely go see they killed her.
They killed her ass.
My favorite one was there was a story
about one of the enron whistleblowers
who committed suicide by shooting
himself in the head twice.
I'm not kidding.
He shot himself in the head twice.
I wish I could remember the,
the full details of
thIs story,
but the that's the coroner's report was
that he shot himself,
which I guess is possible.
You could shoot yourself in the head in
a fucked up and you're still alive,
but your,
your fight clubs and you know that you,
they didn't remember it.
Dalton's character like blew off hafiz.
Yeah.
I got bored with that movie once I found
out who was two different guys.
I was Like,
wait a minute.
What?
You just faking it now?
So this guy wasn't even real.
Wait,
wait a minute.
What the fucK that I watch then dude,
would you rather watch that or parana?
Pronto was pretty darn.
It was cocky as fuck.
But if you're in the mood for the
chicken to face ripped off the
propeller.
It was cool.
That was nasty.
Fuck man.
There was totally ridiculous though.
Most ridiculous.
Will we ever fucking.
I liked jerry o'connell,
gIrls kind of wild.
Oh,
awesome.
Right.
That was pretty cool.
I mean,
if there's anybody that you can root for
getting their dickie.
Jerry o'connell,
I still liked him from stand by me.
No,
not him.
You know,
I'm saying that girls gone wild.
Guy goes,
yeah,
yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Play the character.
I was watching hd net the other night
and uh,
uh,
some dirty shit and I understand that
man kind of wild thing and I was
watching that girls kind wild guy,
like hanging out with those girls.
I'm like,
that would be the saddest thing ever if
that was your daughter,
if your daughter was hanging around with
that dude.
You're like,
oh shit,
are you watching this?
You see what's going on?
This guy really,
he's even creepier to me than hafter.
There's something super creepy about
that.
She often made hefner,
I would love to get to the playboy
mansion.
That man,
I'm not that big a deal.
It's just a house in the hills.
It's like,
it's kind of like dated,
you know?
I mean,
I guess it's like retro,
but the grotto has like this old circuit
box,
this old phone.
It's a dope house.
it's a beautiful piece of land and I'm
not saying,
I'm just saying when you get there
you're like,
oh,
well let's just kind of a cool house in
the hills.
It's just one of those things where
everybody likes to put parties there and
so that's what they kind of sell it as.
Right.
Force has done it.
I've been to.
I've not had one a few weeks ago that
was relaxing and boxy.
Cassandra simon from h.
Then it went to the well in that way
it's kind of a cool place to go,
you know,
to go see something there.
Yeah,
it's kind of a cool.
But I've been at parties there before
they get.
I guess they get crazy.
That's what tomorrow I got to New York
for the first time.
I'd never been to New York all the times
I've been here to the us.
I've never been to New York.
So tomorrow we're getting the death star
five nights when you drive up the west
side highway and,
and,
and you just see the enormity of the
city as it starts to rise in front of
you.
Play star wars music while you're doing
that for real.
Really ask,
ask if you could drive in on the west
side highway if that's possible and
asked,
you know,
if you could play the star wars music.
Just a tough time.
The first time I drove there from boston
I couldn't fucking believe how big it
was.
The first time was in the citY.
I was,
well I went twice.
I went once for a karate tournament in
madison square garden back in like 1982
or something.
Yeah,
yeah,
there was a tournament there.
Yeah.
And then there was,
I think it might've been,
I don't know if it was,
there's two parts of the gardens is a
smaller part in the bigger part.
I don't know how much they,
how much space they had.
I was young,
I barely remember it,
but when I came back to do as a standup,
I was,
you know,
no much more aware of what was going on
and when I drove up I drove up the west
side highway and saw it for the first
time.
I remember going,
damn,
how fucking big is this?
Like why did they keep building here?
If you been to tokyo know you haven't
been yet.
Now I'm going to come with me to k one
and when you say it is fucking insight,
it's last sort of sidekick and drive for
40 minutes or an hour and it's still
built up.
Skyscrapers they never fucking in.
You look out your window and all tHe way
to the fucking horizon.
All you see is concrete.
It is fucking that.
Is it bigger than New York?
I think it's be a land wise.
Well there's 30 million people in 30
million of the fuckers in tai chi man
and still nobody jaywalks can you
imagine?
You've got shavaya crossing the busiest
crossing in the world and fucking
thousands upon thousands of people.
But In Japan,
no one jay walks.
I'd been walking at 4:00
in the morning when I'm jet lagged for
4:30
in the morning.
There's not a car in sight for fucking
miles and I'll be standing next to a
businessman and he still will not
jaywalk 4:30
in the morning.
We'll wait for the little man to turn
green.
Why is that the fucking weird luck
zombies over there.
Everything is regimented on the streets.
No one screamed.
No one swears no one because their
horns.
There's no graffiti.
Everyone's small.
So each other.
Everyone is good.
Yes to each other.
It is like a fucking mind boggling,
overly polite utopia.
If you're into that sort of thing.
If you could speak english,
it'd be.
It'd be amazing if they spoke english.
It is an insane real is insane at the
fight shows you've seen the fight to you
here.
Super drop.
You can hear a pin drop steve.
Thousand people.
40th 5,000
of dynamite last year.
We used to do it for k one and still
they appreciate moves and get golf clap.
You know,
you get a fucking golf clap.
It's.
It's an amazing culture.
Amanda.
The tokyo experience.
I want you to come with me one day and
your fucking why would love it
to,
to go see k one.
I've always wanted to see a k,
one grand prix live.
I've always want to see that.
Yeah.
It's got to be.
I'm a big fan of it and that's one of
the reasons why I love hd net fights,
you know,
it's like fuck,
finally,
you know,
may have,
and I were talking about it when we did
inside mma.
I sold that with the cuban cuban on
that.
Oh,
it was great.
We were talking about how it used to be.
If you wanted to watch k one,
you had to get these fucking grainy vhs
tapes or get some shit off the internet,
but now you can watch it and high def,
you know,
it's fucking awesome.
Carrie,
what you.
Some of the people don't know how
exciting that is,
who don't know k one because most of
what people like in the ufc is striking.
That's what the average person like
striking people,
boo when shit goes to the ground happens
all the time.
For those people that are just like,
they just want to watch some violence,
what the fuck is more violent in k one
and what?
Who the fuck is more volume than
alistair overeem?
Man,
fucking carry.
Somebody in cracked,
cracked.com
wrote that.
He looks like he was genetically
engineered to fuck your girlfriend.
I'm pretty sure it was cracked.com.
I hope I'm crediting the right people.
that's exactly what it looks to these
fucking frigging.
WhIch leads me to the question now
because when we spoke last time on the
voice versus the whole rage then was
fetal versus brock and we spoke a lot
about final versus broken and you know,
I have to fight all these.
That fights lost its luster completely.
So now everyone is like overeem versus
brock.
Yeah.
Over.
I want to see overeem versus fate or
two.
I want to say that alice said once that
fight badly,
like he is all over.
We did the voice versus alistair
overeem.
We shuttered in Korea and um,
man,
he really wants to fight.
Find out.
Here's the thing with alistair overeem,
you gotta fucking take him down.
There's all that talk of standing.
There's all out the window now.
It used to be the guys can stand without
alastar.
Like chuck stood with him for a bit.
Chuck actually shot in for a take down
with them.
You know the problem with dallin starr
was always that he was trying to make
two.
Oh five.
Yeah,
that was always the problem and he
wasn't dedicated like he is now,
but once I motherfucker went up to
heavyweight and started getting
dedicated.
he's,
he's scariest thing is like last week
and he knocked out ben edwards had bins
in nausea and I've been commentating him
for like six overcoming tough,
tough,
tough guy.
Ellis did dropped him three times But
three clean shots.
And the thing is that usually lsj would
get away with a lot because of his
strength any size alone,
but now he's technique is just superb
man.
And know he was training in Thailand for
like three weeks at the golden glory gym
in Thailand doing proper muay thai
training.
The thai trainers there,
helping them out and you can tell that
he's just lifted his game to another
fucking liberal too.
He's,
he's spooky right now.
Spooky.
His standup.
A spooky,
you know,
I love the fact that he goes back and
forth though.
I love the fact that he goes into mma
and respect back and forth.
The only god doing it at that high
level,
no one else of course.
Level for sure.
not even,
no,
no question.
There's no one even compares to the
level of k one that he's achieved.
And the level of mma,
I mean,
because we've always had guys who say
like,
oh,
he's a real,
he's a really good striker and you know,
they are for,
for mma,
but als stars are really good striker
for key.
Exactly.
But who can adjust to mma striking,
which is very impressive man,
because you know,
the distancing,
the footwork is all completely different
from mma structure.
TaIwan striking.
So to swing between them at the two
highest levels is,
is,
is an insane,
uh,
treated.
When he put it to brett rogers.
I was like,
god,
he fucking threw him.
It was,
it was what it was before he threw him.
He was fucking up on his feet.
He hit brett rogers with.
He ducked under a right hand.
I hit him with a leg kick and then
popped out of the way and you could see
the look on roger's face.
He was like,
there was a job.
am I doing here?
It was a jolt to like,
oh shit.
Like,
you know,
nobody ever kicked him like that before.
To me it was just luck.
You know,
I'll just bend over to get fucked in the
ass because it's going to be less
painful than the beating you're about to
die.
Motherfucker.
Dave's that shin into that meet bob baum
and there was that,
that look on roger's facebook site for a
second.
You saw this fLashlight.
God damn.
He just got hit by lightning.
Fuck lss.
Bit.
I'd be cleaNs up on the.
That's a big problem to me that there's
all these organizations.
If there was just a ufc,
we will know who is.
But alastar would not have gotten to
become our star if it wasn't for
fighting all these other organizations.
you know?
I mean there's not enough fights in the
ufc.
There's not enough.
There's not enough shows.
There's,
there's only so many shows.
Like we need other organizations,
but I just wish they could fucking just
figure out a way to work it out where
they get to fight each other.
We'll come together as friends for one
night for one night.
The problem is,
and then maybe you and I could come and
take together.
Finally,
for one,
it would have to be.
The problem is the ufc is such a much
bigger name and there were so much more
money.
in the end it would lend respectAbility
to forest,
which is like build up the enemy.
Like you can't.
You couldn't really do it unfortunately
business wise.
But fuck brock brock is like the perfect
guy to like sell as like a heavyweight
champion.
Fucking the fucking worried.
You think brock fighting alistair and
the way that he turned on those punches
from cowan.
Oh my god.
What if.
Yeah,
if that was alistair.
And how about those knees?
No one's got nice.
Like alastar alastar knees you into
fucking the one he fucked fuJita ethan,
you put fujita into a coma.
He was out for how long?
He was fucking out for 10 minutes at
least.
Then they took him to the hospital and
he went into a coma at hospital.
He was fucked and ellis has said to me,
because I said to him,
I go,
dude,
do you ever feel any remorse for just
fucking smashing people's faces and
brains and with those needs?
And he goes,
yeah.
He goes,
for gita.
I actually felt really bad after I did
it.
I don't know what about to share a man.
You almost killed that fucker in the
grand prix.
Awful.
Tisha was dead.
He's like,
he had to share.
It was harsh.
She goes,
but fujita,
he actually was troubled by it.
He felt really sorry.
Well,
I think it was cause for geeta had
already been knocked out and been
stopped a few times.
He was old.
It was a legend and man that was body
clearly didn't look the same anymore.
He didn't look like an athlete anymore.
I was just fucking violent.
And yet for James Thompson in dream
standing guillotine,
he just say the muscles in his back.
Well,
he's fucking beautiful,
man.
He tapped.
Detour can also tap veto with,
uh,
getting,
you know,
freaking out.
Stars nasty bro.
He's an ass fucking nasty.
You know what brock lesnar versus
alastar would be a dream match,
but bronx got to get past cain velasquez
is right for,
I wouldn't call it an upset site is
right for an upset,
but I don't call it an upset if cane
beets broccoli,
because cane has all the weapons to be
able to beat brockman chain might be the
motherfucker.
He might be the motherfucker,
you know,
I think brock is a,
is a handful for any man on the planet.
he proved in that last fight that he's
got like a series of ability to overcome
adversity and,
and,
and still,
you know,
like gutted out and make it through.
He didn't tap,
he didn't freak out,
you know,
he covered himself.
I'll,
you're protecting himself and he was
getting bombed on,
but you know,
other than him,
the biggest,
strongest fucking guy in the division,
you know,
it was definitely the best punch her in
the division and no one punches his
heart as carla and comedy.
He's got wrecking balls,
you know,
he just dropped bumps.
So he got through all that,
made it through that first round and
then came out and won it immediately
into the second.
So he's,
he's overcome adversity.
He believes in himself.
He's a winner.
That's all.
Well and good though.
Cain velasquez,
he's a fucking storm that,
you know,
here's something that bob cook said they
were,
uh,
they were talking about one of the
fights.
That candidate just fucking,
I think it was rothwell just ran them
over,
you know.
And uh,
he said,
uh,
well,
you know,
the thing with fight and cain is you
always think that you're just going to
ride out the storm.
And he goes,
put the storm doesn't end.
That is what that guy does.
We had a storm.
Doesn't end it,
just punches and kicks and punches and
kicks and fucking takedowns punches and
kicks and punches,
kicks.
And you're like,
where is this motherfucker getting All
this cardio from?
Does it all with power,
man,
that's the scary thing.
It's fucking we've pal and he doesn't
fade.
He doesn't fade.
He comes out strong.
and the third when he molested check
Congo and that's what that match was.
That was three round molestation.
I mean he took bombs,
bombed big shots on the jaw,
knees buckle almost goes down and then
three seconds later he's executed.
The take down is inside control and he's
smashing them,
you know?
I mean that was just like,
that was overwhelming.
It was overwhelming what he did to that
guy.
Motherfucker.
Dude,
I count my for that.
I'll come back and say tito,
come back in.
Know I'm looking forward to that as
well.
Um,
but may have brock.
Brockton high was going to be nuts.
Are broken cane.
And then man,
I want to say Alice Davis has broke one
day.
Course tickets.
I want to see yellow star.
I mean I would like to see alastar
cleanout strikeforce to.
I would like.
I think if alastar can beat,
reduce,
that would be a huge rematch.
I don't think there's anyone his truck
force,
honestly.
It'll touch him.
Well,
what gets them on the ground?
I bet for doom it has a say in that.
I bet he would try to tap our star.
I bet he thinks he can.
And he did.
You know he's,
he's capable of doing it.
Didn't he do it before?
Didn't you tap out star?
He did,
but like what?
Pride.
Two thousand and seven.
That's true.
But guess what?
Different volume to value we're doing
just getting off of that.
A victory over fate or he thinks he can
tap anybody.
He'll jump in.
Fucking guard guy.
He'll fly and guard on you.
Mr.
Try to lock you up in his legs.
Was there that night and it struck when
fight or tech.
That was surreal.
Watching that ring side.
I bet it was sad.
Was sad.
It was crazy.
No big deal.
Just got caught.
I think it's happy.
It's happy that we're doing.
Pulled it off in volumes.
Bad motherfucker for the g man and he's
also middle.
Sad to actually be prisoner.
The one not with fighter actually loses
now.
That's as opposed to never have been
president if he was ever fight.
Nah,
it's not sad though.
You were there.
It's no big deal.
You can appreciate all the other ones
too.
You know what I mean?
He's a special athlete.
He's a very,
very interesting guy.
To a very fascinating personality,
but he,
the,
the bottom line is the only way to get
through a guard,
like we're doomed because you've got to
train with a guy like we're doing.
And if he was training with guys like
we're doing,
we would hear about it.
We would hear,
oh,
you know,
um,
he just went down and he's spending
three weeks,
so with is going to work on his guard,
you know,
you don't hear about all that shit.
So he's basically working with these
guys that are pretty good.
They're decent and he's got so much
confidence because he's undefeated in 10
years and he thinks he can just fall
into her garden.
You'll be just punched him in the face.
You can't do that with.
Yeah,
it was a capital mistake,
man and I,
that's on another level.
You don't appreciate.
I've rolled with guys like for doing
before and not,
not,
not that level,
but like john jacques machado,
he's another,
he's that level as far as like
international and they just run through
you.
I mean just slap shit on you.
And if you haven't felt that level,
if you're not in there all the time
training with that,
you know,
you can get overconfident.
I bet anybody that fade or puts in his
guard or if it get in,
theodore gets in someone's guard in his
camp.
Yeah,
I bet he just runs through betty.
Just postures up breaks.
Nobody probably taps in with triangles,
but he slaps that shit like a fucking
octopus from hell's just pitching gulen
fucking attacks and adjusts and attacks.
And every time theodore defends,
he gets deeper in the hole and fight or
held on for as long as he could,
man.
But when he broke,
oh my god,
he's fucking tapping was going to.
John broke his arms,
were about to go fate or you know,
he's a bad motherfucker,
but he just made a mistake.
Yeah,
he needs it.
Everybody needs to work with the best
guys.
It used to be that everybody was,
you know,
you can be able to have like this little
camp and it was just you and a couple
other guys that you train with.
But I don't think you can rock it like
that anymore.
I think the levels just gotten too high.
You everyone's got to train with the
best guys.
This is the reason why golden glory in
holland have so much success in k one
and also mixed martial arts because the
best guys are.
They're not only and they'll fight each
other and they'll fight each other and
like semi shell now start.
They're gonna fight each other to find
each other and that will go for broke.
Errol zimmerman fought semi shelter
earlier this year and he went for,
went for broke on semi.
You're not under both from the same gene
and when I spar together over in
holland,
this sparring sessions are as hard as
kaiwan fights.
They have like this day they called me
wednesday and everyone on wednesday this
goes in the gym just beats the fuck out
of each other like a k,
one style fight and these guys are best
mate's.
A saki will beat on zimmerman.
The two best mates were beat the fuck
out of smart.
You know?
That's how they're trained in holland,
but that's normally a golden glory.
That's at every dutch dream.
It's always been the dutch style.
The toe hard,
I completely opposite the ties.
We'll go light into barring pause.
We'll go light heavy on pad
work.
Ties are always ferocious on fucking
pads and on bags,
but inspiring the thai spa light,
the dutch go light on the bags and the
pads,
but they fucking kill each other and
inspiring.
That's such a unique way of approaching
things and just a mate and then you've
got guys like,
you know,
one of the sparring partners is ramon
dekkers man.
I mean ramond dick is maybe the greatest
moines tie fighter ever and he's golden
glory.
One of the head triad is him and call
him as and it just,
it's an amazing checkers,
bad motherfuckers dude.
Windows deckers and rob carmen with rob
cameron,
a to legend.
He's elbows with phenomenal.
Everything about him.
His leg kicks everything and he's super
cool.
Guy.
Rob came is like the nicest,
friendliest guy.
One of my mates trains or used to train
with him,
cost us mandalore the actor,
you know and can't know who that guy is
going to make causing New York.
He's over there promoting sore.
The new soar film that he's gone for
three days,
so glen ketchup and man,
he's been friends with for years and
this dude's fucking bad ass to try to
get a lot of hollywood people are nutty,
man.
Holland's a crazy place.
The red light district and the red light
district.
We,
last time I was there was 2007 and you
can just get weed in the coffee shop and
I've never been any interests.
Took us out for the nine.
Peter likes to party.
Took right?
If you don't know peter,
he's a multiple time k,
one k,
one world champion.
Bad motherfucker still in there
slugging.
Solving.
Still polo forest with a grumpy look.
Fucking good man.
Incredible man.
His body was yoked.
It looks like he's obviously been
trained like a motherfucker.
Just insane guy going.
One of the nicest human beings I've ever
fucking met.
Supernova greets me with a hug all the
time is always laughing.
Just,
you know,
he took us out in $2,007
million right?
Cfo and a few of peter's mates went to
the red light district.
Dude,
all the stories you've heard about the
red light district,
that true.
Well,
peter arts was smoking weed all day.
Fadeaway it's had a fucking case of
joints in his pocket that he would rip
back and he's best made open the third
coffee house in amsterdam in like 1967.
So he was like a pioneer of weed and
amsterdam,
right?
Don't you think people would be
surprised if they found out how many
high level fighters in mma guys smoke
weed.
It's a big.
The shoW there in amsterdam in amsterdam
arena and midway through and then having
to mission.
You'd go outside to the smoking section
and it is just fucking.
We central moving through the midst of
all this marijuana smoker.
He smoked weed when a lot of ufc
champions.
Oh man,
I believe it.
I fucking believe in a lot of the k
guys.
A lot of the mma guys.
I know a lot of fucking nick diaz is not
the only one that has had the greatest
quote of all time.
Nick diaz is fighting tonight.
We're going to see it in half an hour.
Nick diaz had the greatest quote of all
time.
He said,
I don't think pot is getting in the way
of my mma career.
I think mma is getting in the way of my
pots.
I love it,
man.
That's fucking great.
Get in the way of my weed smoke.
Where do you See that video?
That diaz put on youtube after I did the
voice versus made him and he's driving
and he puts the camera down.
How much fucking pumped you actually
fucking smoke.
ThAt was funny.
As fan to the bowl.
Oh man.
Him and his brother.
I loved those times.
Believable,
man.
Those dudes are entertaining.
Unless you get them amsterdam with those
two in there.
Are you kidding me?
That would be running the cafe.
Throw the fucking book is in the
windows.
He could already be over there.
It might be the first people to die from
weed for the first.
We might fuck up the whole cause did the
weed is a menu.
It's like you go to a restaurant here,
you get a giant menu.
There's a menu of weed.
You've got like I'd say about 30
variations to choose from.
We have that here.
It's crazy.
You know,
we hAve that in these medical places.
I'll take you to one.
I'll take you to one more.
We're leaving here.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
You gotta go.
You gotta see this because it's the
craziest thing ever.
You go look at a capital of johnny drama
in ultra truck.
Is that?
Yeah,
they got lollipops sodA.
Really?
All kinds of candies.
Cookies,
cakes,
brownies.
Do you need holland?
Yeah.
Mushroom and the big man.
Big chalkboard.
Like one of those dry erase boards
filled with like different strains and
this is how much it is announced as much
as an eighth.
Amazing.
They have a 50 slash 60 varieties crap
everywhere all the time.
Like sativas very difficult to grow
there.
It's harder to grow than indicas and
sativas space.
We'd.
Well you go to the place near my house,
10 different vArieties that seems
different varieties of sativa.
That's crazy hard sativa,
and when you live in the east coast
where it's illegal heart,
it's fucked to get a good sativa.
You gotta know somebody who's a grower.
It's willing to take a chance to make a
superior weed.
It's like it takes more time and so it
costs more money in the yield is
smaller.
Did when I was in amsterdam,
I smoked or vaporized bone and it fucked
me because peter goes,
hey mikey,
try this,
try this.
It's a bong and I hate smoking,
but I didn't smoke much anyway and I'll
smoke bombs A couple of times,
but to me they feel dirty.
Right,
right.
So you put this thing into my mouth and
I'm likE,
peter,
I can't see anything here.
No effect.
Nothing goes.
No,
no,
no.
This do it again,
peter.
I can't fucking.
I don't think it's nothing.
Oh fuck.
What the fuck comes out.
It's miss.
For people that don't know what a vapor
hours it does is,
it heats the thc to a point where it
doesn't burn the plant material,
but it burns off the tfc and makes a
vapor out of it and visible.
You cannot see It.
I didn't see it.
I didn't know it was breathing.
Exhaling any smoke enough.
You sort of see it,
but it looks like not much.
It doesn't look.
You get used to like see you smoke a
joint.
You take a deep breath,
you blow it out.
There's a big
cloud is one of you.
This is not a big crier.
I was expecting big clown.
I was like fucking.
I wanted her to pure sensation to.
It was crazy.
It was like there's something in the
burning of the plant to.
I wonder if that has a psychoactive
effect.
Like I wonder if there's a psychoactive
effect from the actual burning of the
leaves.
Like maybe together those things like
there's maybe a comms you a bit or
something because there's like hundreds
of different leaves out there though and
shit out there that no one has thought
to smoke.
That is yet to be discovered as
smokeable.
Do you think like there's like the mud
or dirt out there that someone could
maybe roll into a fucking piece of paper
and smoking.
No one's like smoked that mud or shell
or that fucking a sea urchin that you
can smoke it.
This is going to be shit out there that
no one had discovered me.
A furniture plants.
I mean if you look at the amazon Wasn't
marijuana discovered like we discovered
from goats eating it really fucking
ancient days go to a,
hitting it and then go to a swaying in
the paddocks.
So the farmers are like,
hm,
the goats eat these strange looking weed
and they stumbling paddock where we must
try to eat it with withheld you here.
That's what a lot of my friends was
telling.
It might be another urban legend,
but I heard it was goats discovered
weed,
you know,
that doesn't even make sense.
The guides would high on.
I'm fucking know man.
You're telling me there's 10 different
types of services,
whatever.
So vj,
that's fish fish,
cook with.
Oh.
And I was.
When I did that vaporized bong,
20 minutes later I was in a place called
banana bar and some fucking dirty hooker
was shooting these giant deal.
Does that have been pushing,
hitting me in the chest and kick backing
up five pesos.
And she was shooting these giant dildo
is like thick fucking things out of a
pussy and hitting me smack on the chest.
And then another one would come over and
she had like a texture,
like a marker.
She goes,
what's your name?
I got michael.
So she had a postcard and she sticks the
marker in a pushy hoppers over the
postcard.
And dude with perfect penmanship.
Perfect fucking cursive writing her.
I see michAel love banana by like,
oh my postcard from a pussy.
Perfect penmanship.
How does the postcard stay in place?
I've still got her at home.
She had her toes heal her heel because
she squatted over it.
So one of them was carla hall's postcard
as her pussy does this perfectly to
Michael Love.
Fascinating about.
It was fucking incredible nightmare.
I wonder whAt made them come up with
that.
I wonder if they're wondering whether we
need something new for this business.
We are not getting enough people in
here,
but I wonder if this is a top of the
girls do at slumber parties when they're
young.
Yeah,
they're a little bit drunk or movements.
Don't like,
hey,
let's stick a fucking pussy and try.
Maybe you're hanging out with a bunch of
freaks.
You discover these telling.
I want it to go to that guilt again.
How did you know?
At what age do you know you can write
with your pussy?
Imperfect cursive.
If I had to guess,
I would.
I would guess something.
Whatever the equation was involved.
A dude and money.
That's how a pen got up your pussy.
Well,
how do you shoot that or he.
You did a favor for him,
but it's okay.
But did he lift you in a hotel room and
really stuck with me?
A letter wIth the pussy.
When I look at it,
I know that it's you pushing the road.
Come on.
I can't even write with magazines there.
What about the girls on Macau?
If you have been to Macau,
Macau,
Macau is like a 45 minute boat ride from
Hong Kong.
It's between China and Hong Kong island.
Yeah.
It's like the vegas of asia.
It's a crazy madhouse.
Casino silent,
but I've seen some dirty ass sex shows
in Macau with this.
One chick had the dots,
the dots in a pussy and there were
balloons up on the ceiling and with
pinpoint fucking sniper precision,
she would lean back,
fire,
adopt,
pop the balloons,
one after the other.
She's another chick had razorblades
right strung together and she reaches
into her village and pulls out this line
of razorblades one after the other and
you're thinking,
oh,
thAt's bullshit.
That is made of plastic or something.
Then she grabs the razorblades into
show.
One of the ones that came out of her
pussy gets a piece of paper,
slice slices,
a piece of paper.
I'm like,
that's fucking seAt.
Yeah.
You know that's funny that you just
brought that up because there was a
conversation we had on here last week
about the hookers and Vietnam.
WHether or not they really did put razor
blades.
I have seen the ucs blades come out of
the pussy,
so they easily could have done that to
gis,
like stuck a razor blade in there and
then the guy fucks.
I'm going to cut their dick and half.
One of my mates in Australia finger to
go on a club once and he went,
he went to finger her and he felt scabs
inside it.
Oh,
I sent a letter to me.
Shake my hand.
Like I fucking touching that head.
Put a fucking glove on.
Oh my god.
Are you sticking it in your box hunting?
Yeah,
exactly right.
There's some evil shit going on here
guys.
Bowls look disgusting and wrinkled and
shit.
But man unef.
Some girls sometimes they have to get a
mirror and stand over it and look down
and see how fucked up the veggies look
because some girls got some fucked up
poussey's happening,
man.
The ones who have the Big fluffy fucking
like fucking be lips like that.
I like to.
I like that man.
I'm fucking hang down.
Like that's like
trippiest thing ever is.
When you look at female bodybuilders and
you there,
the little dixit,
they're growing the cleat because of the
roy.
It's because I used to editor a
bodybuilding magazine back in the day,
so I used to interview a lot of female
bodybuilders and they cleat comes like
that.
Like a small dick.
but they are,
I never,
I never fucked anybody.
Builders told being in the industry is
like fire the horniest fucking cans out
there,
female bodybuilder fAster and because
all you need to do is touch the big
penis.
Cliteracy and I basically have an orgasm
like insanely sexually excited get.
Sometimes the doctor,
a doctor will put a woman on
testosterone for something like some
sort of an ailment.
Usually they've got skin disease when
they're young,
the girls will go on on a,
on steroids,
on testosterone.
It's a shame because one of my friends,
she's a photographer back home and when
she was young,
I've seen photos of what she was a
beautiful,
beautiful young girl.
But then she started to develop skin
problems and bad acne.
That was something hormonal and she had
to go on steroids to get rid of it.
And then now she's fucking fucked up.
Ugly,
like bad.
the poor thing.
She's fucked up.
She looks like a man named for her.
Behind her back is animal.
No,
she looks like a fucking animal.
But yeah,
she's beautiful.
She was hot when she was young and then
unfortunately young,
uh,
you know,
when she'll,
she'll fucking eight,
nine years old.
What the fuck?
He's a cute kid.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Well,
there are some girls though that started
out really pretty and then something,
some monkey wrench goes along the way
and then the,
the design of the universe decides to
take it back and you're not hot anymore.
Right.
I've seen that happen.
Girls were really pretty when they were
like 13 or 14 and then you graduate high
school and you run into when they're
like 22,
23 and you're like,
what happened?
I saw the girl that I used to fantasize
over in highschool,
lisa,
right at shows that the dude,
the guild that everyone wanted to
fucking hospital shows that it.
Gil shows like the one and I recently
chatted to another friend of mine on
facebook that was at the guild school
that was sister school to our school
back then.
And I was talking about this Lisa Gill
and wonder what lisa is doing now.
I wonder if she's still hot.
She goes,
oh,
I solely lisa recently.
She's got three kids and I've got a
photo of it.
Do you want to see it?
I'm like,
yeah,
bring it on dude.
She was fucking disgusting.
I'm like,
no way.
That's lisa,
my friends.
Like that's what your eat gill looks
like now.
Do you think that she does the same
thing every time she watches k one
Because that's.
Do
you know what the thing is man?
I weighed myself this morning and happy
with the results I was because I lost a
lot of white racial issues.
We lost probably this year.
I've lost about 11 kilos.
What's that?
Twenty four pounds.
Four pounds.
I'm like,
I haven't been this.
Had this least white since like high
school,
so I was fucking huge man.
Like a lot bigger than I am now.
A lot,
lot bigger.
That's awesome.
Kevin james is lost like almost 50
pounds to to love kevin.
James is a great guy.
You know,
irene had no idea who he was really
short.
We came here today.
Well watching king of queens was on tv.
She's laughing her ass off and I go,
hey,
you know,
he's really good mates with joe.
She goes,
joe rogen,
okay.
Yeah.
Joe knows him really well.
He's like in a movie of ease and their
management.
Same.
They really close mates and she goes,
oh,
who is he?
I got to Kevin James.
She just never saw the sitcom just yet,
but he's been in so many movies to now
I'm in Australia as well,
but she just doesn't know know.
Sometimes you don't know.
Sometimes someone will talk to me about
some singer,
like,
oh my god,
blah,
blah is playing here.
I'm like,
man,
I was plaYing in New York next week,
but you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
So I'm going to.
You'll,
you'll be like,
what are you talking about?
Who is this?
And then you find out they've sold like
50 million albums all over the world.
Justin bieber was,
everyone's got justin bieber,
justin bieber.
Who the fuck is this justin bieber song?
Fuck yeah.
And then I heard the song on the radio.
I'm doing this one in the clothing
store,
wherever I was and my to Iran guy.
Who is this?
It's justin bieber.
I'll go,
this is a fucking little kid that
everyone's talking about.
What am I dancing?
I'm watching a video and he gets hit in
the head with a bottle of that.
Somebody throws a water bottle and it
hit someone head and then people think
it's funny and everyone's like passing
it back and forth on facebook.
I'm like,
listen,
you're looking at a little vulnerable.
Twelve year olD kid has probably grown
cunt.
Fucking water.
I mean he was holding on water bottle
like the little fucking man.
Fuck,
he's fucked,
but for no charge at a young age,
his development will be forever.
Excuse already saw in the book shop the
biography of justin bieber.
The kids like 14.
How much of a biography can you write?
What he done?
Has he been fucking got a head job yet?
But what if it was all.
What If we start talking about chicks?
He fucks.
It just makes the justin bieber pussy
diary was like 15.
Just able to secure a real solid boner
for the first time in my life.
I think first pubic hair and photographs
that and puts it in the center of the
boot and the poor kid.
He's very small,
very small and very small for like 14.
Like he's going to be a tiny man.
Little fucking no,
but they,
they,
the girls right now are just like
confused,
like,
well he's up there and he sang in and I
think I want to fuck them or something
and do.
The scary thing is that this,
this scared me the other day.
Erin's telling me about her little
cousin,
my little cousin,
she's 12 years old.
She's in love with justin bieber and so
she says to irene,
justin bieber is a friend of mine on
facebook,
right?
And erin's like,
okay,
thinking you know,
it's a group or whatever that she likes
justin bieber.
She goes,
oh yeah.
And justin and I talk every other night
and he's a really nice guy and I'm going
to.
Irene,
do you realize that some dude posing as
justin bieber on facebook who your 12
year old niece or cousin is accepted as
a friend that he's talking to her and
buttering up a 12 year old every night,
like fucking borchers out there,
pedophile motherfuckers who had
discovered himself as justin bieber
talking to 12 year old ozzie gills on
facebook.
IT just.
it could
just be 12 year old boys,
so I thought you were going to say it
could just be justin bieber,
justin bieber.
Who knows.
Good.
Could just be 12 year old boys.
Get on facebook.
I go on twitter.
I do it all the time.
You know?
Anybody could be doing it.
Hit me.
I know there's a lot of like,
you know like aston kutcher really does.
He really goes.
Justin bieber's not out there.
Twitter and chicks.
I'm done.
He's got a 12 year old girl in melbourne
maybe is trying to set it up for a down
under two.
I'll probably back 24 months by then.
I'll be all blowed up.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean I have it going.
Oh baby,
come to America,
the middle ages only 15 in Australia.
You to wait another couple of years.
How old you have to be necessarily.
You can fuck it.
16,
but you can only fuck someone who is
under 18.
over 18 and fucking 16 year old.
That's smart.
Yeah.
that's good move.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a 16 year olds from fucking.
Sorry,
come on man.
But you guys have a more relaxed
attitude towards a lot of things over
there.
So much more relaxed when you got out of
high school.
Let me ask you this because this is the
big thing in America is America.
Well,
I grew up in newton,
Massachusetts and newton was a,
you know,
a lot of successful people lived there,
know a lot of people who were like,
you know,
doctors and lawyers and they were very
into their kids' academic careers and it
was like,
it was a school where it was like,
it was a very good school,
like really highly rated and everybody
was super ambitious to,
you know,
to get out there and to go to college
and they get things done.
When You guys graduated,
do you feel like this enormous pressure
to like to go make something of your
life that's not really the college
system that you have in the states
doesn't as eastern Australia,
what is,
how do you guys do it?
So we got high school then after high
school,
go to university,
but we don't have frets,
we don't live on campus and we don't
move into state to go to university.
In fact,
in America,
wherever I go,
no one is ever from the state where I
meet them.
It's like you're from Massachusetts,
boston where we're originally from.
Massachusetts,
yeah.
Okay.
So you're From Massachusetts,
you live in,
in California,
everyone is from a different state to
where they were born in Australia.
Everyone pretty much remains wherever
you're born really.
You grow up.
You're born in melbourne,
you grew up in melbourne,
you work in melbourne having family.
Melbourne went to university in
melbourne uni in melbourne.
No one ever goes to match the
university's interstate and moves
around.
Everyone is pretty much where they're
from and there's not really that that
feel of I'm going to go out and conquer
the world and become a politician or
change the world in any way.
It's like,
no,
fuck it.
I finished high school.
I'm gonna.
Relax.
So much.
Go out and conquer.
The world is.
Don't be a fucking loser.
Oh,
there's a lot of pressure.
Go out and get a fucking job.
Let's go get in Australia because our
economy is really good at the moment.
Jozy announced is really good at those.
Really strong against.
Against the us dollar has rallied.
The doll is that the dol is easy to get
bullied,
so you can be a blood job and just claim
the dol to toll meaning welfare.
Oh,
domain and welfare.
Yeah,
and it's decent.
The dozer,
I know people that live solely off the
dol.
really?
That's it.
I get my adult.
how much you get?
Maybe a fortnight.
FortnIght.
What do you pick up your here?
Motherfucker night for that is maybe if
I'm my chicks watching the tutors and
I'm trying to get some pushing.
Fortnight you might get like $200.
Fuck you.
Fuck you in a fortnight in the ass,
darling.
Yes.
Maybe 200 bucks every two weeks.
Two hundred and 20 bucks every two
weeks.
Highly livable.
Live off that.
Yeah.
I guess if you had to,
that's for doing nothing.
That's nothing to what we call an
Australia.
A dole bludger.
Wow.
Yeah,
and there's a lot of those.
Does that keep everybody calm?
So there's always something.
Even if you're a fucking loser,
you always have something you don't have
to rob and steal.
And do you know because you're an
argument for that.
Is there an argument for the idiots are
always going to be idiots.
Losers are always going to be losers.
Just if you give a little bit money,
you know,
who cares?
This is this way.
At least they have something invested
back into the economy,
but now it's usually invested.
Well unless you're a drug dealer will
purchasing alcohol,
but it's far too easy that if there's
too many.
Is that a strategy though?
You know,
like let's let people be fucking losers
and just take care of them and then
there'll be less crime.
Is that makes sense?
I'm asking them.
I don't know.
I don't think it's a strategy.
The dole didn't come in until like 1975
when there was a lady.
You don't have it then if people are
forced to catch up,
right?
People are forced to pay their own way
and,
and you know,
the thing is though,
I know a guy who's on the doll and he
will not get off his ass to get a Job.
He will not even go for job interviews.
he claims that he's got some disability
or whatever,
which he hasn't.
And It's like,
dude,
my fucking Texas that I work hard for my
money and I've got to give money to the
government.
Pay fucking Texas.
Then going your pocket to pay you to
drink alcohol at home all day.
But I would rather give my tax money to
losers and drunks and idiots and people
had no ambition whatsoever.
Then to war,
I would rather.
Oh look,
I don't know what I'm saying.
He goes to war and there's nothing I
could say.
I'd rather put the fucking loses to
work,
man.
It's like,
you know what?
You want the dope.
You're going to fucking go and work in
this plant.
You're going to work in this factory.
You're gonna fucking send these mailers
out.
You're going to do shit.
You're going to go volunteer in fucking
a hospitals.
That's a great idea.
Or in canteen or somewhere where they
need you and volunteer your time and
your services,
your losers per capita in America or in
Australia.
Like what?
The percentage of losers as opposed to
regular people.
What do you qualify as a loser?
As a homeless person?
I'll lose it Just because fuck you.
You lost like you're homeless.
You lost.
I mean,
you might not.
You're not going to be a loser for life.
I'm not saying that this is a death
sentence.
I'm saying America,
if you're outside,
he got a lot of.
It disappoints me for the most powerful
country in the world.
Great America too.
It's satisfied,
man.
You got a lot of insane
people.
You know.
One of the reasons why the homeless
population rocketed in the 19 eighties
just because ronald reagan in his
administration,
they changed the definition of insanity,
so there's a lot of people that were in
fucking the asylums man,
like you're all right.
We were wrong.
You're not crazy to fucking get your
freak on.
I never understood it,
man,
and it's mental illness.
Exposure to people.
Being homeless.
When I was a kid growing up and watching
american tv was watching the brady bunch
and how they used to run away from home
when you're a kid.
I used to think that's how people ended
up homeless or running away from home.
Some people did.
How many people ran away from home and
just became fucked up hollywood?
HavE you driven around downtown
hollywood?
Some irene is holding my hand really
tight.
It's like last place,
last place.
When people look at hollywood boulevard,
this is the center of showbiz in the
world.
The fuck it is.
It's a shit hole.
I will give you more fucked up.
Have you been to Italy?
I've been to rome.
No.
Never.
You want to say the most fucked up site
in the world and this is sad.
You go to the vatican,
the most opulent place on the planet.
You have no Idea the money that is
fucking dripping off every building,
the vatican and the vatican,
and the catholic church as a
institution,
but immediately before you set foot in
the door,
the vatican on the street there are the
most disgusting disfigured.
Now the bIggest you will ever say.
Arms missing.
Fingers killed around eyes missing and
shit on the fucking streets outsIde the
vatican door.
It makes me fucking sick.
Wow.
All right.
because you've got that there.
There is a better can.
You can touch it.
There is some now up disfigured gypsy
woman who is 80 years old and has to
sleep on a dirty cobblestone roman
street every night while the church is
right fucking there.
Wow.
And they don't offer anythIng.
they don't take them in.
They don't feed them.
They'll help was disgusting.
That's so strange.
You would think that you have to just
for show,
you couldn't even allow that just for
show you got a main strip walk is only
one strictly go do to go to the vatican.
That main fucking via that main strip
and they're there and they're just the
most downtrodden,
repulsively,
disgusting beggars you will ever see and
then you're at the doorsteps of the most
opulent place in the world.
It's does my headi man so strange.
It does my fucking hitting.
It's just so strange that they feel like
they could let those people be out front
and that'd be bad for business man.
You would think so right now.
Apparently berlusconi when he came in
term selling bmws and just people park
wrecked five bmw dealership.
Exactly.
The thing is that apparently someone
told me that since I've been there,
bill a scone,
annie has cleaned up all the biggest and
the gypsies or move them,
but I want to know where do you move
them to suddenly realize,
hey,
people pages.
That was lucky in beijing,
the olympic games because I commentated
the olympics in [inaudible].
Did you really do all the boxing and the
olympic games?
Wow.
Fucking 272 fights in 10 days by myself.
Are you a big just by yourself,
by myself.
Really fucking.
You could talk about store my man word,
but you know,
they relocated 1 million people.
1 million people.
1 million were relocated suddenly to
build the ibc,
the international broadcast center for
the media and the carpark.
Oh,
1 million people lost their homes
virtually overnight.
It's like they wake up one morning and
they go,
you're out of here.
That's insane.
One mill.
How the fuck did they?
More than the entire population of san
francisco.
That's overnight.
Did you have no idea?
After going to the olympic games and
spending three weeks in beijing,
I came back and I told everyone if the
fucking chinese,
everyone to take over the world,
they will do it in the space of a
fucking month,
the way they,
the amount of people that have and the
organization they had and the manpower
and the ability and the technology and
having seen that in Japan as well,
that whole region,
Korea,
Japan,
China,
they will fucking take over the world
easily in a month and we might as well
as bend over,
take the fucking rice up the ass and go,
okay,
we are your slaves because seriously,
the olympic games was phenomenal.
It was incredible.
What is it about them that makes them so
dangerous?
WhY is it their willingness to work hard
in their life,
for their,
for their job is their pride,
self pride and national pride do
willingness to work extremely hard for
very little money and just for self
satisfaction and add to that,
the sheer number,
the numbers they have,
the manpower is extraordinary.
Did you go to one of those?
Yeah.
That is kind of training doWn level that
we can relate to.
You go to one of those k,
one shows in Japan and the amount of
people they employed a set up the arena
and set up the ring and the cameras.
It is insane.
People that I see set up jobs for fox
sports back home that'll take two guys
to set up a particular camera.
we'll that.
We'll use 10 guys to set up a camera and
they'll.
They'll get it done in like a quarter of
the time and the ring is taken apart not
by let's say a group of 15 people like a
show in Australia,
but you'll get 300 guys that as soon as
the show ends,
they're coming in helmets and little
cars and that ring is taken down in 10
minutes.
It's,
it's like it's like it's like vultures
going in and stripping the flesh for the
dead animals is because they have so
many people there that they work harder
or like what is it?
So many people,
they work hard but they worked
diligently And they work together.
It's like it's like a colony of ants.
All the ants are pulling together for
the colony.
No one aunt Is just on his own working
on his own agenda.
It's like we're all pulling together and
therefore we form one giant colony of
just takeover wherever we want.
It's fucking amazing.
Scary.
It's amazing.
Well,
what they're able to do with getting
people to work incredible hours and live
in dorms and shit.
That spookiest japanese.
If you ever been inside of tokyo
apartment,
this
room here would be considered a fucking
mansion.
I want you to.
Renting a room in intake.
Your take your apartment.
The bid was in where the kitchen was,
was in where the toilet was or the one
big room.
One big room where we have that here.
We have studios.
you know you can get a studio.
That's basically,
that's it.
It's just a spot to live.
From the end of the bed to the front
door was from here to where that needs
on you.
Wow.
That's how much room you had to move and
the stove is there,
so you can literally target the worst
hotel room ever voiced.
Telltale,
remember,
and then shrink it like rick mirena's,
honey,
I shrunk the hotel room down at.
He couldn't swing a cat in there.
It's crazy.
I've seen some of the guys' apartments
when they show those clips for k one and
for dream and they used to do for pride
where they show the guy's apartment and
it showed where their training is.
There's no room to do shit,
you know,
tiny ass gems to rob his gym where he
trains oreo cookies.
They fucking tiny.
And this little room over there that no
one.
Not many people have pets.
What the fuck is it about people where
we want to stack everybody on top of
each other like that?
What is that?
I have no idea.
Is that good?
Is there something good about not used
to it?
Because in Australia it's happening.
Yeah,
I mean it happens in America.
It happens there.
I mean there's in Australia,
everybody still leaves like you do here
in a house with a backyard in suburbs
and the whole high rise apartment thing
is slowly building and popularity,
but still everywhere you look,
I'm telling you the west side highway
drive is going to freak the fuck out,
but to everyone's stacked,
he kind of pet.
Do you know you can go and rent a pet in
tokyo just to pick one too,
so you can go rent a cat or a dog for an
hour.
She can take it to the park,
throw a fucking little fucking park,
throw little frisbee,
feed it,
take it for a walk.
Then you return it to the shop.
You rent a dog into cat for an hour.
That's ridiculous.
What if you get attached to the dog?
Don't you develop a relationships in the
dog?
Then you could maybe rent it for two
hours,
but yeah,
you just rent a pen.
That's a strange world man.
They almost are like an alien race.
So it really is.
I mean the writing is so different,
so completely unrelated.
If you look at like the writing of,
you know,
all the european countries except for
the hungry a couple of days,
they all share.
They use the arabic alphabet that we
use.
Yeah.
They all share it and you go to China
and Korea and Japan.
It's like,
whoa,
you guys are aliens.
Yes.
This is alien stuff.
This isn't even related to like this
grew completely independent of the
european style writing.
It's so different.
What a better world.
The place will be.
If everyone spoke one language,
would it?
I don't know,
man.
I think it's cool to watch all the
different branches now mad if people
could actually reason with each other in
one single language,
people would go to war over eichler
people or retards.
All you have to this fucking blue odd
cock suckers,
a church of god land dude.
People are dumb.
They find they want to be on teams.
No matter what.
You always want to find him vent one
universal language once wasn't suddenly
called esperanza or something like that
might be someone can clarify on tweeted
towards.
It was like years ago that tried to
invent a language code.
Esperanto esperanza,
it was meant to be one global language
and it never took off,
obviously.
Don't remember that.
Yeah,
yeah.
That would take a long ass time and you
have to get it to the tribes and the
african forest will take generations
because you'd have to school
generations,
three or four generations to get it down
pat and you know,
income cultured among the masses.
Yeah.
Most,
most countries in the world,
you know,
a good percentage of the people are
bilingual and America.
People are,
you know,
just english or spanish.
That's it.
Yeah.
Everyone's like english and I mean
there's,
of course there's the immigrants in here
that speak all kinds of languages,
but as far as like people learning
things,
very few people are bilingual.
How bad the immigration problem here was
to.
I was driving to do a king of the cage
show in New Mexico and the driver was
telling me about it because we're
driving along the border.
They're from el paso to mescalero and
he's putting it out in my head was in
the van with me,
you know,
and the guy's like,
this is where the mexicans from the
border,
this is where they are on the border.
I'm being myself.
What the fuck they do you call if you're
complaining,
what the fuck do you call the state?
New Mexico.
Seriously,
of course you're going to fucking run if
tHe old Mexico is shit and you want to
you except I'm going to New Mexico.
Call it something else that doesn't
matter what you call it over here.
There's money over here.
I appreciate the ambition,
man.
I think it's kind of fucked up that
there's spots in the world that suck and
you can't leave him.
You know?
I think it's kind of fucked up that you
can't just travel from one place to
another and just go wherever the fuck
you want live.
Where are you want?
You know,
we can't let them in.
We can't let them in.
It's like,
really?
You sure we carry brother.
I got held up in toronto for five days
recently because I had visa problems
because something wasn't done properly
on my,
my work visa,
so I've got held up in toronto and the
way they treat you like you're a fucking
liar,
you're a criminal,
you fucking got to rag on your head and
you're roddy.
I came with a bazooka.
Seriously because they're going to bed
like just.
I don't know what it was like.
It could be an arab.
I felt like I was locked in a fucking
detention.
There was a lady studying you now.
There was a french lady sitting there
with three kids and she'd been in that
detention in toronto at the airport for
four hours.
She was crying with the kids for four
fucking hours.
man would have her and her kids are
strapped up with dynamite.
Alrighty.
Everything about that?
No,
no.
You gotta be fucking careful.
Their job is tough.
I like our Canada doesn't let him douche
bags.
They don't know.
What do you solve?
Battery.
Fuck.
You get outta here and under blends
high.
But,
you know,
I think,
I just think as long as you have a aware
of,
you're aware of someone's record,
I think he should be able to go
anywhere.
If you're not a murderer,
you know,
scumbag,
you have real papers.
If Mexico had real pampers,
you know,
in America you do know you run numbers
on people in America,
chances are in 2010 you're going to know
exactly what the fuck they've done.
boat people in Australia,
maN,
that'S how big problem people sailing
boats from East Timor and other places
that ruck up on boats in Australia and
they run off into the fucking jungle.
Fuck.
Yeah,
because Australia is awesome.
Well scott,
I appreciate that.
I mean,
it's like why shouldn't they be able to
do that?
There are people,
I feel like if you
have the means and the willpower to get
somewhere that's better than where
you're at,
we should all allow that.
You know what kind of fucking hippy
commie,
socialist talk nonsense is this boy,
this is America land of the free home of
the brave.
And I'm here with Australia.
My man michael chavela.
Ladies and gentlemen,
strikeforce about starting about 30
seconds,
so we're gonna wrap this up,
the meeting of the minds.
We will do this again,
my friend when you're in town again,
for sure.
I'll be in a couple of months.
We'll be chevelle.
It was a cool motherfucker and I always
enjoy hanging out with them and I always
enjoyed doing this podcast.
You guys are the shit.
I love you all.
Thank you very much and I will see you
probably on tuesday with joey coco diaz
later.